uh how many people are you traveling
with
oh that's a good number what is that uh
hello
i'm doing the beautiful mine numbers
right now yeah
exactly uh i got the numbers in it's
apparently 48.
holy [ __ ] 48 people yeah uh it's
it's yeah it's a carnival how many tour
how many tour buses is that
uh three three three tour buses and
three tour buses and five rigs
what's everybody doing i basically
travel with a special so when people
come out to see the shows
i mean the stage is huge you know if
you're gonna perform
uh at a big arena 15 000
plus it's gotta it you can't just show
up with a stage
and a a a stool and a mic you gotta
you know you gotta give them bang for
the buck so we got giant screens the
stage is all built it looks
like we're gonna tape a special every
single night it looks like we're gonna
take the special oh i love it
dude this is so [ __ ] badass it's like
wwe meets the food network
yeah dude